let me pull it up from nbc i just i feel
sorry for all the girls who got
nominated because it's a huge honor to
even be nominated and to have it be made
a mockery of is so disrespectful
yeah here's a story from nbc news trans
swimmer leah thomas nominated for ncaa
woman of the year award the university
of pennsylvania athlete shot to fame
earlier this year when she became the
first transgender ncaa champion in
division history
now most of you know the story of leah
thomas huh i wonder i don't they don't
have the photo here there's a photo
where leah thomas is standing on the
podium and all the girls go far away and
take a picture together leaving leah
thomas the transgender swimmer historian
to their their lonesome this to me is an
example of the
psychopathy the narcissism the
sociopathy
just all of these like
i don't know i i you know look the point
i was just making for those that are
just tuning into this segment was that
the right has
let's let's start to jonathan heights
research the moral foundations there are
six the right has an equal balance of
all of them libertarians only have one
moral foundation it's hilarious it's a
liberty that's it they don't care about
anything else it's kind of creepy
actually if you look at the questions
asked and liberals have care and
fairness and nothing else
so it seems like you have a tendency
among the right conservatives to have a
balance to their to their views i wonder
if this has something to do with a a
tendency to live in rural areas
like in our experience what happens when
you catch a cute little animal that is a
rabies vector nobody wants to cause harm
to the cute little animal but when you
don't people die right and you have to
make hard decisions and recognize hey
look you're hungry that chicken kill it
who's going to kill the chicken oh no
but we love the chickens they're so
funny
you got you got to do it and i wonder if
that's the reason why people growing up
in cities isolated from all of this have
become narcissists to become egotistical
and have a have an over overreaction
towards the idea of care and fairness
what i've been seeing
on the right
you got your grifters you've got some
people who are uh
notable for copyright infringement just
stealing contents pulling labels off it
and they've done well for themselves and
it pisses people off but for the most
part you have an attempt at honesty
conversation compromise
and then you take a look at the left and
it's it's malicious
it's ignorant it's angry
care and fairness is getting twisted i
think in the sense that if you see
someone suffering people are like oh i
want to make that suffering stop but in
reality
people sometimes need to suffer to grow
to learn about themselves they need to
go through pain and hardship and like
it's called tough love it's a very
specific thing and to eradicate that and
make sure that people are comfortable
frequently without resistance they're
going to fall
i have to wonder about it though man
my experience with even even today
the people on the right
that i'll talk to for instance sheamus
is a great example oh yeah james gets
mad when i when like when we argue about
abortion and i say like i think there
are circumstances where it's the
government should not be intervening and
sheamus freedom tunes good friend he's
very pro-life and thinks there should be
a nationwide ban on it and we disagree
and we've gotten heated and then we
write jokes together and we laugh
together because you know we really do
just want to live together and and and
hope we can do right by each other and
then chambers also knows you're going to
hell so he he wins the long game well
sheamus doesn't want me to go down
he's trying to save us all yeah no he is
i mean but he literally is yeah no i
know for his beliefs in his view that's
what he's trying to do and uh when we
argue about it we get angry but
afterwards we're laughing we're having
pizza
working together
but with the with the modern iteration
of whatever the left is the reason why
people like you jamie or you taylor are
now all of a sudden being associated
with the right for whatever reason is
because there's an open conversation on
the other side of those flames on the
left you're surrounded by a wall of fire
and they tell you if you go near it
you'll be burned and that's why people
are scared to speak up and won't but on
the other side of it we're chilling
you know it's a it's this this is like
um it's like that movie the village you
ever see that that i'm not shy yeah
they're in the village they don't yeah
it's it's also like uh there's that
breitbart court i have to bring up and
then forget the other side of the fire
well i don't know you want to pull it up
again
so uh you know andrew breitbart had a
quote about the fire and then someone
told me a different version of it but
i'll let and i always forget what the
quote was and then i asked him to look
it up
toward the fire quote let's see it walk
toward the fire don't worry about
what they call you all those things are
set against you because they want to
stop you in your tracks but if you keep
going you're sending a message that
people are rooting for you who are
agreeing with you the message is that
they can do it too
so i was talking you guys may be like
andrew breitbart too i know right what a
day for me you know he used to be a huge
liberal i do remember didn't he uh start
like huffington post with ariana yeah
yeah right so
someone would told me about that quote
and then what they said was think of it
like you're surrounded by a wall of fire
and everyone keeps saying if you go near
that you'll be burned don't go near that
and then eventually someone starts
walking towards it with all them
screaming stop you're crazy you're
stupid you're wrong don't do it they get
violent trying to stop you and then the
person jumps through the fire
and now they're on the other side and
what do they see it's a beach people are
hanging out with cool crisp air they're
drinking beers they're laughing they're
swimming
people are taking off to go home and
everyone else trapped inside is too
scared of what's on the other side or to
go near the flames the flames it's the
wokeness it's
if i speak up against this person the
woke people will attack me and destroy
me well some people get attacked and
destroyed regardless yeah and that's a
great
i'm laughing i'm laughing so hard
because
i mean even when the even the beach part
of the metaphor everyone was like you
can't for years you can't go on tim
pool's show you can't go on tim pool's
show then i show up here and you're like
we have swords and guitars and i'm like
this is amazing great this is so fun we
got drinks we got fancy whiskey
people of different political views oh i
burned my eyes on pappy's i never
thought that would happen right this
metaphor of the fire being woken is
brilliant because if you get near it and
then you mock it it's going to burn you
if you if you but if you pass through it
you're fine there's so much more outside
of this cult well and guys i have great
news i'm gonna i'm gonna do the ian i'm
gonna look straight to camera and say
this twitter isn't real yeah like
twitter isn't real the times where
you're getting mobbed or you're in an
argument you go outside birds are still
chirping man you go to starbucks person
the cashier will still talk to you you
can still have a normal conversation
with people you can still say hi you can
still pet strangers dogs like it is not
real and the majori i truly believe the
majority of people align with us where
they're decent people they want
everybody to have rights they're not
following the news they don't know they
don't know about what marjorie's writing
on facebook they just want to take care
of their family but the fire that's is
that's woken is moving it's burning and
and if you sit still if these people
outside the fire are fine but the fire
will move and surround them if they're
not aware of what's going on
i think you're half right i think that
my story is a really good example of
that because people were telling me from
the very start that i ruined my life and
i was never gonna have a career and that
i should just like hurt myself and leave
skateboarding leave the internet but
my life has only gotten better i've had
more opportunities i've gotten to
actually speak up about this issue
and have a bigger platform for it which
is important to me that's why i spoke up
in the first place so for those that
aren't familiar you compete in a
skateboarding contest against a
transgender biological male and came in
second and now you're speaking at big
events i i don't want to make
announcements for you but you've been
speaking it a lot yeah i've been doing a
lot and i'm really grateful for that and
i'm grateful to work with a team of
other women who are either athletes who
have gone through a similar experience
or doctors or attorneys who support us
but
had i not just committed to what i said
and just gone through that fire
like for lack of a better term
than it would have just passed and there
was a second where you were just getting
burned right
for a moment before you tweeted before
colin writing colin wright tweeted
tweeted and then i saw it oh shout out
colin yeah thank you colin you're the
best he bought me hot chicken in
nashville this is awesome
i think i think it was his girlfriend
christina who showed him the story so
shout out to her too so let's let's
let's wrap this all up together the
analogy is actually perfect you were
warned to stay away from the fire even
though it sucked where you were and you
were like this this is bad it was worse
just feeling like miserable about not
speaking up for myself but then you
heard me you walked to the fire and the
first thing that happened was you got
burned and people started just crapping
all over you well on the internet not in
real life no for sure it's like the burn
doesn't kill you it hurts but then all
of a sudden colin wright grabbed your
hand and pulled you out of the fire on
the other side colin writes rad dude
were we're big fans we've had much
several times and his girlfriend i got
to finally meet him in person and he was
so cool
well and actually and i'll give props to
you too taylor by speaking up
what like i didn't i was so scared and
so filled with shame with mine that i
was just like i'm gonna disappear i i
literally still thought i was talking
about this with joe at a show like i
it was so culty where i was like by me
not defending myself still makes me a
better ally like i didn't want to say
anything that would make me sound like i
was trashing any women so i just stayed
quiet and because my only fans were
super woke people
everyone was just like they got their
marching orders and they bailed so i
didn't have
backup and then by me staying quiet
there was no one defending me you know
what i mean like joe texted a couple
people texted but for the most part i
just i went dark and and just started
teaching jiu jitsu and so
when taylor did speak up for herself
like that does go to show
how powerful it can be when you really
believe what you
believe what you preach and also when
you just go no i'm not gonna take crap
and i'm gonna defend myself right away
there are people who will back you up
which is rad you know what like the best
piece of evidence that the right is not
a cult is that our good friends over at
patriots.win routinely call me cuck
in other words
but still but still routinely watch my
content and then insult me over it
fellow cultists can still call you a
[ __ ] beware no they hate me
i don't know that's true the point is
they they smack talk me they smack talk
joe they're like these people are weak
but that right there shows they're
sharing content outside of their circle
right they're sharing things that other
people are saying explaining why they
think we're wrong and why that deserves
to be called a cuck or whatever and i
made a point i said this actually shows
they're not in a cult well because they
watch people they disagree with to learn
what they're saying the cult isolates
you from everyone else and ironically by
watching something that uh they
shouldn't be watching kind of makes them
a cuck
what do you think about the term self
imposed
i refuse to accept that that wasn't
funny and i was like i will sit and
someone's going i will sit in this
silence so you guys figure out that
this video is going to live on
yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
tim cast irl come hang out live monday
through friday at 8 pm eastern time
super chat we'll even answer some of
your questions if you want to check out
the after hours censored show go to
timcast.com and become a member we put
those up monday through thursday at 11
pm they're very funny not very family
friendly we'll love to see you there
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you